bonsoir et bienvenue nous sommes en
direct c'est ça vous regarde et je suis
ravi de vous retrouver au sommaire de ce
soir les défis qui attendent elisabeth
bornes la nouvelle première ministre
était ce matin à l'assemblée elle s'est
posée en chef de la majorité elle met
cap sur les législatives mais aussi sur
les urgences à traiter dans le pays
pouvoir d'achat planification écologique
relations avec les syndicats bornes une
femme pourtant agitée c'est notre grand
décryptage dans un instant sur ce
plateau les projecteurs du monde entier
sont braqués sur lui mais que sait-on
précisément de volodymyr zelensky notre
grand témoin ce soir retrace son
itinéraire hors normes dans un livre de
charlot à churchill l'ancien comique
muet en chef de guerre héroïque a aussi
sa part d'ombré nous en parlerons avec
gallagher fenwick qui lui consacre une
première biographie enfin nous
retrouverons nos a franchi pour leur
parti pris ce soir elsa mondain gabaye
son carnet de campagne des législatives
fanny guinochet pour l'économie le plein
emploi objectif possible ou impossible
en cinq ans et puis la sémiologue
mariette darrigrand va analyser pour
nous la paix les appellations désormais
officiel première ministre voilà pour le
menu c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs une femme première
ministre plus de trente ans après edith
cresson mais pour quoi faire on va
débattre ce soir des chantiers qui
attendent elisabeth borne à matignon
bonsoir jean rémi baudot gêné merci
d'être avec nous journaliste politique à
france info chroniqueur dans cette
émission chroniqueur politique bonsoir
béatrice mathieu on sera ravi de vous
accueillir à nouveau sur ce plateau chef
du service économie à l'express pour
soir jean françois julliard jean merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes directeur
général de greenpeace et puis
l'historien jean garrigues va nous
rejoindre dans un tout petit et ce temps
il préside le comité d'histoire
parlementaire et politique mais qui
mieux que lui pour nous dresser le
portrait de cette techno de gauche notre
nouvelle la première robe ministre si
j'ai bien compris c'est stéphane
blakowski bien sûr
[Musique]
bonsoir alors si j'ai bien compris la
grande nouveauté dans ce pays ce qu
emmanuel macron annonay la tête du
gouvernement quelqu'un qui porte une
veste bleu ciel waouh incroyable à
regarder je n'invente pas une veste
bleue ciel est ce qu'on avait vu edouard
philippe mendes bleu ciel ou tron et les
jugeant qu'à spec mais tsonga ste rose
non pas du tout en fait c'est une image
de se mettre à feu ne s'est pas excusé
mais pour le reste il n'y a pas grand
chose de nouveau puisque elisabeth
bornes dans sa veste bleu ciel a quand
même été trois fois ministre pendant le
premier quinquennat et vous savez
pourquoi
parce que c'est la meilleure avec ma
grosse comme ça quand on est le meilleur
ben voilà on est promu dont il a été
nommé à matignon ça c'est assez logique
le problème c'est qu'on nous avait
promis du renouveau mais du coup c'est
pas tellement le renouveau quoi ses amis
c'est une femme quand même tu as fait un
changement non ah oui mais c'est ce que
je disais elle m'a une baisse bleu ciel
alors moi j'ai des baisses bleu marine
pas bon femme ça va c'est pas non plus
pas moi j'ai des amis je connais des
gens très bien qui sont des femmes c'est
pas non plus un énorme problème mais en
même temps ouais c'est comme ça et là
c'est avant tout quelqu'un de brillant
elisabeth board mais à chaque fois la
ramène à la baule poste on la ramène à
le fait que c'est une femme alors
pourquoi est-ce que leur ai pas le droit
d'avoir une baisse le ciel morose on
s'en fout de la couleur mais en 2013 ça
lui est déjà arrivé elle a été nommée
préfète de la région poitou charentes je
pense et c'était le même commentaire
hein une femme a été nommée préfète non
mais incroyable c'est une première dans
la région le nouveau préfet du poitou
charentes et de la vienne est une femme
elisabeth bornes c'est son nom a pris
officiellement ses fonctions ce matin
une femme dans l'uniforme de préfète de
la région poitou charentes c'est une
grande première elisabeth borne est
aussi la seule femme en france
métropolitaine à occuper cette fonction
donc on me fait remarquer qu'elle
n'avait pas de veste bleu ciel elle
avait comme un petit chapeau fantaisie
assez mignon quand même un bon accueil
en fait c'est un peu l'histoire de sa
vie en fait à lisa mais de bandes
cherche depuis tout petit elle
s'aventure dans des domaines qui
normalement sont réservés aux hommes
elles racontaient sachets hanouna on
voudrait vous montrer le témoignage n'a
pas vendu bon choix pour quoi
tient ce qu'elle raconte est un beau
témoignage a raconté qu'à la mort de son
père quand elle avait simplement 11 ans
et s'étaient réfugiés les mathématiques
parce que ça permettait un pet de
juguler un peu la détresse qu'elle avait
ressenti il a fait tellement de matches
à 20 ans elle est entré à polytechnique
est donc déjà je pense qu'à 20 ans quand
elle est entré à polytechnique avait 6 %
de filles dans les colonnes du daily
mais vous êtes une femme et comment vous
avez fait pour rentrer à polytechnique
croyable alors c'est une femme certes
c'est une femme de gauche alors je serai
peut-être un petit monde c'est une femme
ça c'est sûr est-ce qu'il est de gauche
employant le conditionnel saurait de
gauche parce qu'elle a travaillé avec
jospin à matignon avec ségolène royal
elle est au mitard d'écologie m'enfin ce
comptage veut dire n'importe quelle
personne que retravailler dans un
gouvernement de gauche serait de gauche
et là c'est la porte ouverte à toutes
les fenêtres écouter alexis corbière
alors emmanuel macron est un homme de
gauche c'est c'est absurde ça détruit la
pensée de réfléchir comme ça emmanuel
macron a été ministre de de françois
hollande alors avec votre critères macro
est un homme de gauche à droite un homme
de gauche comme il a eu sa carte au ps
pendant un v6 2009
et bornes dont elle elle n'a jamais pris
sa carte au ps vous savez techno c'est
comme ça alors
donc un petit zemmour peut-être ce qu'on
voulait se demander si on reconnaissait
les qualités des alizés bat bornes bah
oui on en reconnaît aussi le courage ce
matin qu'on a demandé à adrien captens
était courageuse il a posé dire non on
écoute
adrien 4 n'en serait pas là alors on
parle de s'écouter lé candidat c'est une
bonne chose j'espère qu'elles soient
battus en toute hypothèse quel que soit
son sort personnel je de sa part ou
balades à dos ben je je je sais pas faim
le est-ce que c'est spécialement
courageux oui et nous parle de courage
peut-être à witbank foyer il reconnaît
elle qu'elle est courageuse donc ça veut
dire qu'elle est vraiment très très
courageuse et même l'opposition lui fait
ce cette concession est d'ailleurs
jordan bardella l'a dit lui a aussi
implicitement ce matin quand on
l'interrogé avec des camarades lcp on
lui a demandé comment il voyait les
choses et voiliers implicitement il dit
la même chose voire cinq personnes qui
refusent matignon je pense qu'à quelques
années se serait pas vu or ils ont
refusé parce qu'on l'agenda qu'on leur
demande de mettre en oeuvre va être très
violent et donc ils savent que faire le
premier ministre l'a nommé c'est que
première ministre en tout cas nommé
c'est que l'inflation vient
l'explosion des prix des carburants
vient la retraite 65 ans va être très
difficile admet dans un contexte les
gens sont divisés sont fracturées
donc voyez moi je sais pas comment
conclure si ce n'est que je m'alignerai
plutôt sur carole delga et valérie
pécresse qui ont souhaité bonne chance
à elisabeth bornes ou une tante que le
mieux qui puisse lui arriver c'est que
fillon là on l'appelle babette dans un
an ou deux bains vraiment la greffe a
bien pris avec le pays mais là on se
prononce merci pour ce pour ce regard
stéphane jean rémy c'est donc elle c'est
tout sauf une surprise
ça c'est sûr non est ce que c'est le bon
profil idéal ou est ce que c'est un
choix par défaut parce que son nom
circulait déjà il ya trois semaines ça
il ya un proche des manières macro qui
me disait hier soir elle est ce que le
président veut depuis début et ça c'est
ce qui nous raconte maintenant à
posteriori de la nomination d'elizabeth
dans la réalité effectivement c'est que
comme ils disent elles koch toutes les
cases tout le portrait robot emmanuel
macron avait fait de son premier
ministre guy bricout logique écologique
social productive si la dimension
produits donc effectivement elle et elle
et son c'est son portrait robot la
réalité concrète c'est qu'elle a été
pressenti en tout cas son nom est sorti
très tôt probablement trop tôt que
d'autres noms sont sortis entre temps on
imagine effectivement qui maniait macron
avait gardé en tête comme comme
peut-être son meilleur plan b
d'autres noms qui ont circulé et in fine
à au final bien en fait au finish c'est
elle qui l'a une proche d'alexis colère
finalement resté soudas veut dire que
c'est en ligne directe très rapprochés
avec l'elysée tout ça on a notamment dit
que ce week-end alexis colère avait fait
en sorte que puisqu'il ya d'autres noms
qui sont sortis notamment catherine
vautrin de droite eh bien on il a été
dit beaucoup que alexis colère ce
week-end avait beaucoup travaillé
beaucoup oeuvré pour que ce ne soit pas
vautrin on sait aussi que elisabeth
borne a été soutenue largement par
l'ailé gauche de la macro ni richard
ferrand des personnalités comme
christophe castaner encore clément boon
qui ont largement oeuvré pour pour
qu'elle y arrive elle n'arrive pas dans
un terrain totalement conquis il faut
quand même le dire puisque la droite de
l'amac rognés notamment
en gros ceux qui sont encore aujourd'hui
enfin ce qui était ministre jusqu'à hier
soir jusqu'à hier 16 heures la voix un
petit peu arriver d'un mauvais oeil et
ça commence à tirer un peu dans les
oueds déjà oued
super après l'arrivée dans ce parc jean
garrigues merci d'être avec nous on va
parler de cette question voilà d'une
femme parce que quand même c'est pas
rien et il a fallu attendre trente et un
ans après et discrétion il était temps
il était temps vraiment oui il était
temps dans le la classe politique sans
doute l'une des plus machiste de de
l'europe démocratique je trouve que ça
me paraît assez clair
on est on est pas mieux ne pas mieux
placé que nous en tout cas on a eu
beaucoup de retard on a eu du retard ne
serait ce que pour accorder le droit de
vote aux femmes donc on a on est un pays
qui a eu beaucoup de retard on voit bien
on peut l'expliquer
il ya des tas d'explications le temps
politique est long dans notre pays pour
ce genre de choses là la parité
notamment l'explication majeure elle et
j'allais dire elle tient ou au poids de
la société du catholicisme dans la
société française aussi pendant pendant
très longtemps et aussi au poids de
préciser c'est assez contradictoire au
fait que sous la troisième république
lorsque les autres pays ont donné le
droit de vote aux femmes le parti
dominant qui était le parti radical
était un parti ultra laïcs qui justement
craignent l influence de l'église sur
les femmes et on sait par exemple que en
1974 où c'est je crois que c'est tout et
c'est en 1974 si si les femmes n'avaient
pas voté valéry giscard d'estaing
n'aurait pas été élu président de la
république des si on mettrait paris en
bouteille
il ya une réticence et tout est la
réticence elle tient d'ailleurs à toutes
les sociétés politiques je dire que les
hommes sont pas prêts à laisser leur
place mais mais je trouve que dans la
société française particulièrement dans
la classe politique française je pense
qu'elle est elle est même en retard par
rapport à la société française elle même
on va parler des chantiers qui
l'attendent sont nombreux elle arrive en
terrain miné on l'a bien compris
béatrice mathieu seulement pour
comprendre parce qu'on nous dit ok c'est
une femme mais c'est avant tout une
techno est ce que est ce que c'est
vraiment une femme de gauche c'est pas
parce qu'on a été dans des ministères
des cabinets lionel jospin ségolène
royal qu'on est forcément engagé à
gauche est-ce que les baisses que la
scène de gauche comme vous voulez c'est
une techno de gauche allemand sous la
voyez
pratique et
c'est une techno de gauche gauche bon
teint entre eux c'est quand même et très
social démocrate comme il n'en existe
plus aujourd'hui mais
alors les dossiers sociaux elle les
connaît très bien parce que c'est une
femme aussi qui vient du privé elle a
été aussi l a été à la ratp donc les
syndicats elle les connaît c'est
négocier elle s'est négocié à la
négociait la ratp elle à négocier quand
elle était aux transports sur le dossier
sncf elle à négocier quand elle était au
travail sur le dossier de lier en
juillet pendant cinq ans à elle sait
négocier l ai vue donc pour en avoir
parlé par exemple avec les verriers de
fo qui dit elle est dure mais les
droites
mais les durs c'est mais en même temps
quand elle dit qu'elle valait j'entends
c'est
l'envers parce qu'elle aura une part de
liberté la dernière fois jean castex on
lui a imposé son directeur de cabinet
très important un directeur de cabinet
c'était nicolas revel on a appris son
nom aujourd'hui pour elisabeth bornes
c'est aurélien rousseau vous le
connaissez il dirige l agence de
régionale de santé de france est-ce que
celui là il lui impose et aurélien vous
souhaite un la choisit alors est-ce elle
l'a choisi je sais pas de relier un
ruisseau fait partie quand même d'une
galaxie très proche de macron puisqu'il
est
l'époux de marguerittes 15,9 qui est la
numéro deux de l'assurance maladie qui a
beaucoup travaillé sur le programme des
manuels macron
c'est quand même dans c'est je sais pas
si elle est sous surveillance j'en sais
rien je ne pense pas mais en tout cas
elle est très bien épaulé j'aurais aimé
y avait des conseillers communs entre
l'elysée et matignon sous jean castex ou
edouard philippe notamment en ce moment
on a vu le déjeuner à l'elysée le
premier ministre est supposé présenter
un certain nombre de ces choix mines et
de ministres au président la réalité
c'est quoi ces mâcon qui propose le
gouvernement l'été c'est
qu'effectivement dans un cadre on n'est
pas dans une cohabitation le président a
tout toute latitude pour en fait
effectivement imposé le aussi des
engagements politiques que lui a pris
c'est à dire que sa nouvelle majorité sa
fédération ensemble il va devoir à
travers des postes et bien rétribués
symboliquement et à travers des
portefeuilles un certain nombre de
partenaires et c'est ce qui va expliquer
évidemment la composition qu'on va voir
dans un instant vous disiez c'est
utiliser une expression un petit peu dur
consanguins sur sur les histoires de de
direction de cabinet etc on pourrait
aussi se rappeler que par exemple les
débuts de jean castex que jean castex
l'aï repart avec le sourire et tout le
monde a l'air de le trouver fort
sympathique ce qui est certain ce qui
est manifestement le cas mais faut quand
même se rappeler qu'en coulisse dans les
premiers temps on disait
l'interministériel c'est n'importe quoi
ça ne se passe vraiment pas bien et
c'est donc l'arrêter de castaic c'était
aussi ça notamment au début à partir du
moment où
les habits de banque va arriver avec une
autre expérience ministérielle et avec
dans un bassin qu'elle connaît déjà avec
des personnalités qu'elle connaît déjà
ou si effectivement la ligne et 15,9
c'est mon vélo peut l'appeler comme ça
c'est peut-être pas en termes
d'efficacité politique pure c'est pas
forcément rien enfreint jean françois
julliard on va revenir sur ce qu'on
appelle maintenant la planification
écologique on leur montrait un reportage
à ce sujet parce qu'elle a évolué mais
quelle est votre réaction
géré depuis tout à l'heure on a dit à
plusieurs reprises qu'il ne suffit pas
d'avoir appartenu au gouvernement
socialiste pour être de gauche moi je
dirais qu'il ne suffit pas d'avoir
dirigé le ministère la transition
écologique pour avoir une fibre
écologique donc on attend on attend de
voir elisabeth bornes danser dans ses
nouvelles fonctions on jugera sur pièce
vous savez ça fait cinq ans qu'on a été
un peu baladé entre des effets d'annoncé
des effets de casting on se souvient la
nomination nicolas hulot alors certes
pas premier ministre mais numéro deux du
gouvernement on nous promettait qu'il
aurait l'écoutent direct des manuels
macron qui l'aurait l'attention du
premier ministre on sait ce qu'il en est
ce qui s'en est suivie la continuité
dans l'immobilisme mais mais oui mais
c'est un peu ça oui mais en même temps
c'est juste parce que depuis hier avec
les équipes de greenpeace on essaie de
se remémorer ce qu'est les abeilles bord
n'a pu apporter de positif sur les
questions écologiques a été un an en
charge de ceux de ce ministère là et on
a du mal à trouver très honnêtement elle
est là elle a conduit on va dire ça
comme ça une loi climat qui a conduit à
décréter l'état d'urgence climatique
donc symboliquement c'est une bonne
chose mais en même temps elle n'a pas
été en mesure de rehausser l'ambition
climat de la france qui est toujours de
viser moins 40% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre à l'horizon 2030 contre
l'union européenne vise moins 55% donc
on voit bien qu'elle n'a pas réussi à re
c'est l'ambition on va revenir dans le
détail sur cette question est ce que
c'était a l'ambition c'est difficile en
tout cas aujourd'hui a tout à prouver
sur les âmes est borgne je voudrais
qu'on fasse un petit détour par les
législatives parce que rien ne sera
possible si elisabeth board ne gagne pas
dans le calvados sa circonscription
c'est celle de caen vous allez nous dire
si c'est gagnable sur lui ai donné parce
qu'elle arrive un petit peu un de
parachute
quelqu'un qui a fait beaucoup de
politiques par le passé mais d'abord
puisqu'elle était à l'assemblée
écoutez christophe castaner ravi d'avoir
une nouvelle chef de la majorité
je ne doute pas qu'elle soit totalement
engagés pour cette campagne ce avec elle
même d'ailleurs est aussi candidat dans
le calvados et qu'elle souhaite
maintenir sa candidature ce qui est une
prise de risque je salue cette prise de
risques là aussi et donc elle sera
engagée dans la campagne à nos côtés
évidemment et par fonction le premier
ministre la première ministre et la chef
de la majorité parlementaire et nous
sommes fiers de cette chef alors les
législatives j'aurais mis c'est une
étape préalable très clairement c'est le
père elle s'en va oui c'est très un dock
à la logique la réalité c'est qu'elle
arrive dans une dans une confrontation
qui est assez gagnable donc c'est la
circonscription de alain tourret qui de
mémoire alors j'ai déjà un tout petit
doute mais qui a été réélu à ses hôtes
enfin aux lamas g1 plus de 60% si si ma
mémoire est exact
enfin qu'ils étaient
quand à 120 la question sont pas
rationnels si j'ai bien compris en fait
là qu'un des attaches personnelles et
intimes dans dans la région et donc je
trouve que ce procès est peut-être pas
tout à fait le plus
il faut mener la bataille des
législatives pour lui donner un élan une
légitimité dès le départ ne l'ont pas
tous faire les premiers ministres ça me
paraît indispensable bon à la différence
de jean luc mélenchon ça moi ça me pose
un problème que je veux que méchant 20
veuille devenir premier ministre en ce
sens est d'accord ni la députation mais
c'est l'essence et à co2 côté we ll a
besoin d'être d'être d'être élu pour
incarner cette chefferie de la majorité
en réalité pour moi le chef de la
majorité dans un système comme celui d'
emmanuel macron ces manuels mâcon il
faut pas se faire d'illusions tuer le
dire tant pis que que nos institutions
et je le déplore ont subordonné les
majorités parlementaires à la majorité
où la personne prenne
elisabeth bornes pardon qui sera dans
l'hémicycle pour le discours de
politique générale si elle est réélue
dans le calvados après les législatives
c'est pas je dirai comment dire une
grande figure des discours c'est pas
l'art oratoire elle n'a pas l'habitude
il va y avoir probablement plus de
députés de la nuque en tout cas de oui
le lac hoan nouvelle coalition emmenée
par jean luc mélenchon à l'assemblée
comment vous voyez les choses elle va
devoir imprimer sa marque difficilement
ce nous prédit des a-10 telles
assemblées quand on écoute l'opposition
était déjà très difficile pour edith
cresson en 1991 ce n'est pas un exercice
facile de toute manière bien peu l'ont
véritablement réussis et n'en retient
que deux ou trois dans l'histoire
peut-être celui de jacques chaban-delmas
et encore qui avait provoqué beaucoup de
remous avec georges pompidou non c'est
un exercice difficile ce n'est pas faire
injure réalisé baseband que dire qu'elle
n'a pas un talent tribunicien je ne vois
pas comme un orateur
peut-être que le discours sera bâti de
telle façon kilt qu'il sera performant
qu'il pourra intéresser de toute manière
c'est le fond qui prime est ce que si si
son programme est à la hauteur des
ambitions parce que les ambitions sont
grandes il ya l'ambition écologique est
majeur et qui est une vraie nouveauté
viendra navire en termes de projets et
puis à la méthodologie aussi et donc ça
ça doit se se concrétiser déjà dans ce
dans cette déclaration de politique
générale y va de toute façon elle ne
sera jamais assez à gauche pour les
députés qui seront élus par du côté de
la nuque donc ça une certaine manière il
faut faire une croix dessus après il ya
la question de son poids politique à la
question de savoir est ce que c'est une
bonne oratrice le fera peut-être des
choses un peu corsetée au départ on
espère qu'elle peut-être grandira dans
cet exercice il ya la question de son
poids politique évidemment pour elle
dans la majorité telle qu'elle existe
actuellement c'est difficile avec un
françois bayrou avec un edouard philippe
qui prennent beaucoup de place et on
sait que le patron de l'assemblée
voudrait garder va certainement gardé
est à la manoeuvre et va garder la main
ce soir là le rôle politique de
l'animation politique de la majorité au
sens large donc pour elle c'est sûr que
ça va être un job difficile et c'est
aussi pour ça qu'elle est attaquée
d'ores et déjà un parent par
l'opposition par la droite par l'extrême
mode sur son côté chef de cabinet d'
emmanuel macron en fait et
collaboratrice la collaboratrice et donc
ça ça pour elle ça va être difficile de
s'imposer là dedans alors c'était dans
tous les cas on y vient qui va piloter
la planification écologique l'expression
reprise par emmanuel macron est de jean
luc mélenchon au départ dans cette
campagne sans doute nous dit on vous
allez nous dire j'en ai mis si c'est
vrai ou pas dans deux ministères
différents l'un sur l'énergie l'hôte sur
les territoires évidemment tout ça avec
prudence parce qu'on attend la
nomination il annonce du nouveau
gouvernement dans les jours qui viennent
écologie version elisabeth bornes c'est
signé stéphanie des pierres regarder
l'ancien dirigeant de la ratp est elle
une écologiste convaincue en 2019 alors
qu'elle est ministre des transports ça
ne saute pas aux yeux n'en déplaise aux
détracteurs de l'avion je préfère une
petite ligne aérienne qui désenclave
rapidement et efficacement à la
construction de très grandes
infrastructures de ligne à grande
vitesse juillet 2019 elle passe des
transports à la transition écologique
emmanuel macron n'a pas tenu sa promesse
de 2010 est d'interdire le glyphosate
la france essaie de réduire sa
consommation de pesticides mais le défi
est colossal en mars 2020 elle met la
pression sur les agriculteurs nous ne
sommes pas sur la bonne trajectoire
on peut soutenir l'agriculture bio mais
de façon générale les agriculteurs
doivent transformer leur pratique
association climatologues tous louent sa
fine connaissance des dossiers lors de
la convention citoyenne sur le climat
elle se dit favorable à la limitation à
110 km/heure sur les autoroutes et elle
a plutôt laissé un bon souvenir aux
participants notamment grégory frati qui
depuis soutient la majorité
présidentielle avait trouvé inistre avec
août qui était ministre de travail et
qu'il y avait la conviction écologique
entrer en mer et ça pour le coup c'est
plutôt un bon signe après est-ce qu'elle
aura la latitude h à la politique
qu'elle soit le patron des écologistes
ne lui laisse même pas le bénéfice du
doute elle a pas de bilan au ministère
de l'écologie elle avait souhaité
appliquer les propositions de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat ben
on n'a rien fait elle avait même
souhaité un référendum évidemment il en
a rien été le président a jeté tout ça à
la broyeuse c'est la continuité d'un
mandat qu'il ya un quinquennat
d'inaction climatique elisabeth borne
n'a pas attendu cette charge il y a deux
ans encore ministre de la transition
écologique elle défend des son bilan en
rappelant celui des verts et les verts
il était au gouvernement
au début du quinquennat précédent est-ce
qu'ils ont fermé les centrales à charbon
est ce qu'ils ont arrêté notre dame des
landes est-ce qu'ils ont arrêté le
projet europa city est ce qu'ils ont
est-ce qu'ils ont accompagné les
français pour supprimer un million de
chaudières fioul comme on est en train
de le faire est-ce qu'ils ont permis de
sortir de la cité de la circulation un
million de voitures polluantes donc moi
je n'ai pas de leçon à recevoir
désormais à matignon elle a toutes les
cartes en main pour porter plus loin son
bilan vert elle n'a pas forcément tort
d'agréer né comme ça le bilan écologique
de les manuels macron dire qu'elle n'a
rien fait comme le dit julien bayou que
cette convention climat et l ami à la
broyeuse c'est violent quand même vous
êtes sur cette ligne là aussi à
greenpeace on est sur une ligne encore
une fois qui est qui est sévère mais
juste c'est à dire que on a on a parlé
nous d'un quinquennat de perdus pour
l'écologie pour le laisser passer oui
perdu parce que tout ce qu'elle a
égrainé
mais c'est ce sont des projets qui ont
été arrêtés donc ça n'améliore pas la
situation c'est juste qu'on évite de
d'empirer en accumulant un certain 2
mais ça mais c'est ce sont des mesures
qui sont trop bien trop faible face à
l'urgence climatique la rénovation des
logements les associations qui
travaillent là dessus que ce soit
fondation abbé pierre emmaüs et tout ça
dénonce le fait que les chiffres avancés
par humaine le cros emmanuel macron qui
parle de plusieurs centaines de milliers
de rénovation thermique en fait son
héros de ce sont des rénovations que
très partielle c'est à dire qu'on change
nos fenêtres et c'est considéré comme
une rénovation en coche une case
rénovation
rien en termes de réduction de la
consommation d'énergie donc ça
n'améliore pas les questions
environnementales climatique et ça ne
résout en rien les problèmes des
personnes qui vivent dans le dans
l'inconfort dans ce logement vais vous
donner de noms qui circulent à moudre
avec prudence vous l'avez compris cette
planification donc elle l'a piloté le
temps long c'est rare qu'on commence à
se dire en quinquennat il va falloir
maintenant on a compris que c'est des
sachets ans à 2030 2025 2030 donc elle
pilote ça peut-être avec pascal canfin
sur la planification énergétique et avec
les noms circulent évidemment je les
jette comme ça dans ce débat mais
évidemment ils peuvent changer ce serait
là guest firmin le bodo proche d'edouard
philippe pour
la question des éoliennes pour le dire
vite la planification sur le territoire
qu'est ce que vous en pensez rien très
honnêtement rien et c'est l'idée de
scinder en deux alors l'idée de scinder
en deux elle et elle n est pas
inintéressant se dire que la question de
la planification on va pas faire comme
si c'est pas une idée à laquelle les
années c'est une idée intelligente sur
le papier ça c'est sûr de penser le
temps long de se fixer des objectifs qui
vont au-delà de ce quinquennat et au
delà des échéances électorales immédiate
ça c'est absolument nécessaire sinon on
n'y arrivera pas le temps climatique n'a
rien à voir avec le temps politique et
c'est sûr que si on n'arrive pas à
travailler sur le temps long on n'arrive
à rien globalement on se retrouve avec
des mesures très court-termiste qui ne
vont pas dans la bonne direction sur les
questions environnementales et
donc à une prise de conscience dont il
ya quelque chose d'intéressant et on va
examiner ça de près de scinder en deux
les questions énergétiques les questions
de planification
on l'a mis on avait fait un
exercice de mobilisation citoyenne il ya
quelques mois qu'on avait appelé les
boules et du climat pascal canfin il
faisait partie de notre sélection des 10
boules et du client voulait bien sûr
parce que parce que là c'est ce qui le
président de la commission environnement
en présidant effectivement cette
commission européenne cette commission
environnement parlement européen il fait
aussi le jeu en ce moment il ya tout un
tout un travail sur ce qu'on appelle la
taxonomie c'est à dire la classification
des investissements durables ou non les
volets européen pascal canfin a soutenu
le gaz et le nucléaire dans cette
classification là ça ne nous voient pas
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui si on est
sérieux avec les rapports du giec il
faut sortir des énergies fossiles gaz
compris et le giec a clairement expliqué
dans son dernier rapport que la solution
ne viendra pas du développement de
l'énergie nucléaire qui est une énergie
qui s'est disqualifiée d'elle-même dans
le sens où elle est trop coûteuse et
trop lente à déployer c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui si on a entendu emmanuel
macron qui veut construire de nous de
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires ces
réacteurs ne vont pas voir le jour avant
au mieux 2035 tout le débat sur
l'écologie mais il ya aussi des
engagements sur l'offshore léognan
bien sûr bien sûr mais mais mais c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas
convaincu
au fond emmanuel macron nos contrats
jamais les grandes associations qui
défendent l'écologie non parce que déjà
le choix du nucléaire parce que
finalement un premier à premier
quinquennat qui a déçu mais parce que je
pense aussi que comme il ne vient pas de
là il n'a pas le coup de tampon qui
correspond à qui je pense va dans le
sens du message intransigeant que vous
portez poser des questions que j'ai pu
régulièrement posée les manières macro
tout au long du quinquennat en le
suivant sur le terrain et je me souviens
que dans un déplacement par exemple au
japon avait dit je suis un nouveau
converti chez la fois des nouveaux
convertis et
convainc pas pour autant excuser cette
fois j'en ai discuté avec des ddd des
collaborateurs de deux des dix bornes à
l'époque où elle était au ministère de
la transition qui elle est arrivée elle
n'y connaissez pas grand chose elle
s'est plongée dans les dossiers après le
6 et me voilà la question qui se pose
est alors ça c est ce qu on peut devenir
écologistes ou est-ce qu'on est obligés
de l'être j'allais d'avoir son coup de
tampon alors c'est une question
l'écologie qui est souvent en lien avec
l'économie est forcément d'ailleurs
c'est notre avenir la conversion vous
l'avez vu vous béatrice mathieu
d'affairé annuel macron
la conversion en tout cas une prise de
les passer du productivisme à l'urgence
climatique pour le dire simplement qu'en
mai une prise de conscience on peut pas
dire qu'il n'a pas eu la prévention sans
doute il ay il a eu kylie kylie pas
envie de renverser la table comme vous
souhaiteriez peut-être l'a renversée et
ça ça me paraît aussi évident il est
dans une comment dire une écologie ou
entre le mot sur vos grilles étaient là
qu il le prononcer alors que j'avais de
décroissance mail annonçait dans la
campagne c'est tout nouveau tout le
monde mais ce qu'il veut un peu derrière
ce mot sobriété parce que quand on
regarde les rapports du shift project
sur ce qui est vraiment la sobriété or
en termes de baisse delà de la demande
énergétique c'est considérable donc bon
il est sur eux une écologie une
transition écologique en modèle pour
dire
molle sans doute pas à la hauteur de ce
qu une partie des ong environnementales
espère la question c'est les choix il
fait un choix qui est de garder le
nucléaire moi
plutôt sur 7 sur cette ligne là je pense
que le nucléaire doit faire partie du
mix énergétique comme le solaire comme
l'éolien comme l'éolien offshore et on
va rester sur la méthode parce qu'on va
parler maintenant des syndicats mais
vous serez aussi j'en suis certain a
mené certaines amenés à aller voir
elisabeth borne à de nombreuses reprises
à matignon on va arriver sur des
dossiers sociaux évidemment le gros
morceau béatrice mathieu ce sont les
retraites mais aussi et plus près de
nous la question du pouvoir d'achat on
voit cela avec hélène bonduelle board vu
par les syndicats
les syndicats vont donc dorénavant à
négocier avec une femme première
ministre
il a priori c'est une bonne nouvelle
c'est une bonne nouvelle d'abord c'est
une femme c'est vrai que c'est assez
choquant même totalement choquant dans
l'histoire de la république française
parce que dans la cinquième ce soit
simplement la deuxième femme à accéder à
cette fonction éminente ne peut que se
féliciter que qu'une femme soit première
ministre et d'ailleurs faudra il faut
éviter tous des propos machistes telle
qu'on n'a pu les entendre par le passé
et qu'on entend encore parfois dès
qu'une femme prend des responsabilités
elisabeth bornes ancien ministre des
transports puis du travail son visage
est bien connue des syndicats est passé
les politesses la plupart évoquent une
ministre dur en affaires le souvenir de
quelqu'un d'assez frande assez directe
qui connaît bien ses dossiers mais qui
ne cède jamais aucun pouce de terrain
sur les sujets que nous avons eues en
débat à wil écoute mais elle entend pas
mais elle est comme monsieur macro moi
je la connais côtoyé comme une et du
travail c'est rugueux parfois dans la
confrontation il faudra sans doute faire
un effort d'écouté de construction
davantage un dialogue rugueux dont se
souviennent les cheminots lors de
l'impopulaire réforme ferroviaire trois
mois de grève dure et une concertation
qui n'auront pas suffi à faire plier la
ministre le prochain gros chantier
social du nouveau quinquennat la réforme
des retraites s'annonce lui aussi
houleux et malgré le changement de
méthode prônée par le président réélu
les syndicats restent sur leurs gardes
elle est très difficile à convaincre
donc il nous faudra nous être à la
hauteur on a bien l'intention de l'être
on a la connaissance précise et en
détail de tous les paramètres du dossier
des retraites est ce que nous attendons
c'est quelle est cette capacité à la
fois d'être celle qui dirige le
gouvernement et pour le coup c'est elle
a cette capacité est bien que elles
tiennent compte de ce que nous aurons à
lui dire si c'est pour discuter
librement de la question de la retraite
avec l'objectif de réduire l'âge de
départ à la retraite nous irons si c'est
pour augmenter l'âge de la retraite non
quand tous les syndicats en france sont
contre une mesure ce qui est rare ce qui
est rare ça devrait pour quelqu'un qui
écoute à devrait déboucher les oreilles
les retraites le pouvoir d'achat les
salaires trois thèmes que les syndicats
devraient défendre bec et ongles dans
les prochains mois
face à la nouvelle première ministre
elle écoute mais elle entend pas est ce
qu'il ya au fond de quoi négocier c'est
ça la question puisqu'on parle d'une
nouvelle méthode que le président de la
république réélu veut absolument porter
il veut changer de méthode donc
forcément conférence sociale etc ou des
partenaires sociaux est-ce qu'il ya du
grain à moudre sur ces quelques gros
chantier pouvoir d'achat retraites
salaires pouvoir d'achat ils sont en
train de préparer de toute façon à quai
pour la rentrée est présent chez qui
seraient présentés en fonction des âges
et à des élections législatives en
juillet où il y aura effectivement un
certain nombre de mesures qui seront qui
seront présentes ont l'âge c'est plutôt
consensuelle
à la
presse sur le smic effectivement où on
voit bien que l'argent du midan sont
maintenant mais la barre un peu plus
haut on demande à un smic à 1500 donc ça
c'est de côté vers les retraites sur les
retraites ya deux chantiers sociaux qui
vont arriver très vite premier sur les
retraites deuxième très vite l'assurance
chômage puisque en fait le paquet de
l'assureur reste un bon thé non
maintenant qu'ils avaient été négociés
finalement l'accord qui avait été
négociée tombe à l'automne et eu
tellement de recours finalement qu' il
va falloir commencer à renégocier tout
ça dès l'automne avec ce qu'avait
présenté macron pendant
la campagne un peu éclair de dire il
faut finalement adapté la durée
d'indemnisation à la conjoncture donc là
effectivement les syndicats sont assez
content d'autant plus qu'il arrive en
disant regardez la conjoncture elle est
plutôt en train de se retourner on a une
croissance maintenant atone 0,1 0,2 mais
qui baissent plus donc la négociation
sur l'assurance chômage va être
compliquée sur les retraites on voit
bien que c'est le bras de fer social
sera très dur c'est alors qu'un des
fêtes fut très dur avec
finalement une le gouvernement de
maquereaux à avancer sur le dossier
retraites en masquant finalement un peu
son objectif est ce un objectif de
finances publiques il veut faire la ola
la réforme des retraites pour hors
équilibre à trouver de l'argent c'est
investir ailleurs pour financer autre
chose notamment la dépendance alors un
dernier tour de table pour essayer de
savoir quels sont vos infos coulisses et
comment vous d'analyser la situation
nouvelle méthode vous y croyez ou pas et
au fond les retraites c'est vraiment le
gros morceau est ce qu'il va la faire
vite elle va la faire vite auquel cas il
ya moins de temps pour la négociation ou
au contraire quitte à prendre du temps
il va falloir voilà peut-être la
différer un peu il me semble qu'on aura
la réponse dans les toutes prochaines
heures les tout prochains jours quand on
aura la composition du gouvernement
parce que les personnalités qui vont
composer son gouvernement au delà de
toutes les listes qui circulent nous
donnerons tout ça ça nous donnera la
couleur non mais en fait je suis venu
avec justement une de ses listes qui
circulent qui évidemment ne n'ont rien
de 2,2 forcément très crédible et tout
ça mais c'est assez drôle parce que
c'est nice qui circulent jusqu'au
jusqu'à l'elysée avec les gens disent
mais est ce que c'est vrai ou pas donc
c'est assez rigolo et ministre entre eux
selon voilant vos journalistes en fait
c'est assez drôle
c'est assez étonnant bref au delà de ça
cette liste la vraie liste in fine à une
fine et ça nous donnera vraiment là la
température et la manière dont vraiment
emmanuel macron envisage cette nouvelle
méthode s'il a un gouvernement qui est
très proche de l'ancien ou qui pardon
sauf que la nouvelle méthode c'est du
temps et une réforme qui prend du temps
aussi compliquée elle peut elle peut
s'enliser dans le pays je regardais
comment vous vous sentez l'atmosphère
croissance atone inflation les taux
directeurs qui vont augmenter la dette
qui explose on est quoi on aide à
nouveau au pied du mur et va y avoir une
colère sociale il est certain qu'on est
au pied du mur et en même temps avec je
dirais à la suite des crises qui se sont
succédé l'impression qu'il ya quelque
chose à réinventer dans la société
française pas que moi je pense que cette
impression
l'abstention de montres etc qui est au
delà même du dialogue social le dialogue
démocratique et je veux dire que il me
semble que il ya du chemin à faire aussi
bien de la part du pouvoir jupitérien
techno verticale que mais quesnel
moqueront apportées presque à fait
d'accord interdit naissance mais que des
de la part des corps intermédiaires même
affaire je suis un peu inquiet quand je
vois les réactions d'emblée les plus
brutales surtout venant des politiques
de casse sociale pense qu'il ya des
choses à faire du côté des regards mon
bénéfice du doute parce qu'il ya un
nouvel élan et ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'on m'a posé la question de savoir
s'il y aurait de nouveau des grands
débats sur les questions énergétiques
par exemple et tout ça moi j'ai dit
qu'aujourd'hui on est on est plus dans
le temps des débats de la concertation
c'est à dire que les solutions elles
sont connues il faut les mettre en
oeuvre donc l'acceptation citoyenne pour
arriver à descendre aujourd'hui on bat
on a fait et puis on a vu ce que ça
donnait que la convention citoyenne pour
le climat moi je n'ai pas envie qu'on
reparte dans ses mouvements de de
consultation comme celui là maintenant
il faut mettre en oeuvre un certain
nombre de politiques publiques qui sont
nécessaires sur les questions
écologiques il faut avancer avec des
actes concrets on n'est plus dans le
temps du débat
propositions pour faire pression merci
beaucoup merci infiniment d'être venu
débriefer voilà ce gip lui 1,7 à annonce
de la nouvelle premier ministre première
ministre qu'on attend évidemment
j'aurais mis avec impatience la
nomination du nouveau gouvernement merci
à vous on voit s'arrêter à présent sur
un destin hors norme celui de volodymyr
lnd qui rien ne prédestinait cet ancien
comédien à devenir président puis chef
de guerre incarnation de l'héroïsme et
de la résistance de tout un peuple avant
d'accueillir le journaliste gallagher
fenwick qui lui consacre une première
biographie française retour en images
sur les grandes étapes qui ont marqué la
vie de cet homme hors du commun à la
cata guilda
c'est l'histoire d'un homme devenu chef
de guerre malgré lui qui propulsé en
première ligne d'une histoire qu'il n'a
pas choisie n'a plus aujourd'hui qu'un
seul but arraché la paix pour son pays
son histoire à lui comment sont 1978 à
kryviy rih ville dortoir à l'est de
l'ukraine pollué par les hauts fourneaux
de l'ère soviétique
le jeune volodymyr étudie le droit mais
il préfère jouer la comédie il se fait
connaître en gagnant le championnat
d'humour de sotchi en russie il avait un
acteur danseur chanteur il devient
l'homme le plus populaire d'ukraine il
se spécialise dans la satire politique
comme dans ce clip pour il joue la
maîtresse de poutine pour dénoncer
l'invasion russe de la crimée en 2014
qu'est ce que tu fous tu es tu as vu
leur
ont discuté de l'invasion militaire
de la crimée tu me prends pour une
idiote
je regarde les infos russe - il n'ya pas
d'invasion crimée
il connaît la gloire quand netflix
rachète sa série sous louera nardou
serviteur du peuple diffusé à la
télévision ukrainienne il incarne un
petit professeur d'histoire devenu
président par accident en 2018 la
réalité rejoint la fiction la star du
petit écran est élu à la tête de
l'ukraine
le 24 février 2022 le destin de
volodymyr et lynch qui bascule dans la
nuit le kremlin donne l'ordre d'envahir
l'ukraine quelques heures plus tard le
président ukrainien enfile le treillis
il fait savoir aux russes qu'il est
prête à négocier en vain la russie
poursuit sa guerre volodymyr zelensky
devient alors le visage d'une nation
prête à se battre pour sa survie
nos garçons et les filles et tous les
défenseurs de l'ukraine ont empêché les
omis de mettre en oeuvre le plan
d'invasion de la russie les ukrainiens
font preuve d'un réel héroïsme
retranché au palais présidentiel
volodymyr zelensky n'a pas peur de se
montrer son arme la communication 2.0
vidéos quotidiennes conférence de presse
en treillis discours en visio devant les
parlements occidentaux pour demander des
armes aujourd'hui après 83 jours de
guerre il n'a pas abandonné son rêve
être l'homme qui ramènera la paix en
ukraine en s'asseyant peut-être face à
vladimir poutine
bonsoir gallagher fenwick g merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vont
signer cette première biographie
française hélène ski l'ukraine dans le
sens et aux éditions du rocher comment
vous avez enquêté on comprend tous
évidemment quand on a un héros voilà qui
fait l'histoire sous nos yeux qui est
sur ses épaules une part du destin de
l'europe mais il ya aussi un mystère on
découvre évidemment que ce comédien etc
mais c'est cette énigme là qui vous a
intéressé vous êtes allé rencontrer ses
proches oui bien sûr l'idée si vous
voulez c'est de dépasser les grands
titres de l'actualité les tweets les
vidéos vous avez montré dans l'excellent
sujet qui vient de passer à l'instant
sur instagram etc afin de donner un peu
plus de relief à ce personnage afin dans
une certaine mesure aussi de moins à
subir cette actualité au centre de
laquelle il se trouve
en essayant de comprendre qui il est
d'où il vient comment ils veulent aller
sur les sites et bien sûr mais
finalement évidemment il a installé
aujourd'hui de manière très claire c'est
à dire que à l'heure actuelle le
président ukrainien veut se consacrer
sur l'actualité uniquement sur celles ci
donc la réponse qui m'a été fait jouer
la cite dans le texte les biographes
après la victoire néanmoins j'ai eu
accès à son cercle premier la directrice
de l'information du bureau présidentiel
la directrice de l'école qu'il a
fréquenté pendant des années dans sa
ville natale de kribi kryviy rih pardon
dans le sud est de l'ukraine et où il a
rencontré certaines des personnes qui
l'accompagnent encore jusqu'ici avait
rencontré valérie et des cantons voilà
alors justement tout part de cette ville
natale j'avais pas prononcé cette j'y
arriverai pas écrivez ville
métallurgique du sud est du pays il est
tourné vers l'est en fait c'est ça qui
est intéressant zelensky tout-petits dès
l'enfance c'est l'urss à 13 ans le cren
devient indépendante il a 13 ans mais
pendant des années c'est vers l'est
qu'il regarde c'est vers moscou il est
russe au fil évidemment qu'aux fans mais
surtout russophile et ça on le sait peut
absolument et c'est très important
d'abord pour comprendre la relation
qu'il entretient avec le voisin qui
aujourd'hui un voisin agresseurs et
auquel il ne vous absolument pas une
haine viscérale
bien au contraire quand il se présente à
l'élection présidentielle sa rue
sophonie et salue russophiles y lui
valent même d'être soupçonnée d'être une
marionnette de vladimir poutine ou en
tous les cas du kremlin envoie des
affiches de campagne avec le core 2
hélène ce qui met la tête de vladimir
poutine et puis on lui rappelle des
déclarations qu'il a faites comme en
2014 lorsqu il y a le maidan la fuite du
président d'alors le pro-russe
ianoukovitch et qu'il va à la télévision
et qu'il s'adresse directement à
vladimir poutine parce que c'est un
comédien très connu dans l'espace
postsoviétique les russes le connaissent
la d'or comme les ukrainiens et dans les
autres pays et il dit
j'ai des milliers d'amis en russie s'il
vous plaît monsieur poutine ne fait pas
couler le sang dans les stones est la
rupture c'est quand même 2014 absolue
d'annexion de la crimée c'est le
basculement il fait des études de droit
mais finalement c'est le théâtre et la
comédie qui très vite le passionné avec
des amis m'ont une troupe d'ailleurs des
amis il est très fidèle c'est très
intéressant le voit bien le dire il est
d'une loyauté à tous ses amis du début
c'est incroyable et entre belle-ile et
les monty python il monte cette troupe
très vite beaucoup de succès à la
télévision quel comique veut-il être
dans ces années là on a vu dans le sujet
alors c'est un peu plus tard mais qu il
pastiche poutine en étant on étend sa
maîtresse il ya aussi du politique dans
zelensky le lait maurice le comédien il
fait du politique sans en avoir l'air
c'est le propre de la satire quel
comique est ce qu'il est c'est du
burlesque souvent vous parliez de benny
hill mais lui préfère les monty python
la vérité c'est que l'héritage qu'il
revendique c'est celui de charlie
chaplin donc un comique qui est très
drôle mais qui sert à faire quoi à
railler les travers de la société la
corruption les dictateurs les hommes
forts mais en étant toujours très
conscients des lignes rouges auxquels il
faut faire attention c'est à dire moquer
mais sans insulter ce qui est
extrêmement difficile dans un contexte
où beaucoup d hommes forts qu'ils
raillent l'humour n'est pas forcément la
première de leurs caractères inizan a
dit un mot ce soir qu'est ce qu'il a
parlé en visio depuis kiev au festival
de cannes exactement et là on a une
réunion en fait de beaucoup des
caractéristiques ou des qualités de
volodymyr zelensky et il s'adresse au
monde du septième art ce soir même
l'ouverture du festival de cannes et il
dit au cinéma ne soyez pas muets et nous
avons besoin justement d'un nouveau de
charlie chaplin pour faire quoi et bien
comme dans le film culte de charlie
chaplin le dictateur dénoncé le
dictateur qui aujourd'hui divise par la
barbarie alors que le propre du cinéma
explique tim de pick and c'est de
rassembler dans la beauté son immense
force c'est le verbe c'est le charisme
mais c'est aussi la communication et ça
depuis des années bien avant qu'il ne
soit élu président de la république on
voit très bien comment ils utilisent les
réseaux sociaux comment ils se filment
dans sa voiture comment il fait rentrer
les journalistes dans le bureau
présidentiel est évidemment comment il
parle au monde entier à travers les
parlements ou ce soir le festival doucet
lui vient c'est inné chez lui c'est
alors il ya une part d'inné il ya
énormément de travail c'est un besogneux
saelens qu'il travail très très dur si
vous voulez la métaphore ou la
comparaison que j'utilise c'est qu'il a
l'apparence d'un jouet pour enfant mais
en réalité c'est une lame de rasoir se
dire que si vous vous y frotter vous y
opposez vous risquez de vous couper
c'est quelqu'un qui travaille très dur
il a le verbe haut il est charismatique
vous l'avez dit il a une très forte
capacité d'improvisation et surtout ce
qu'il a compris c'est que dans le
dispositif de guerre contemporain la
communication est une arme de
destruction massive et il a compris
comment rentrer en résonance avec son
peuple
le galvaniser et en cela être l'un des
principaux piliers de la résistance aux
côtés de l'armée et du peuple justement
mais en allant également conquérir les
coeurs et les esprits bien au-delà de
ses frontières par ces mots simples qui
servent des images très très forte afin
que chacun en dehors de l'ukraine ou en
tous les cas dans l'univers occidental
vous et moi ressentent jusque dans la
chair certaines des douleurs éprouvées
par les ukrainiens alors il ya aussi
dans ce livre et c'est en ça qu'il est
passionnant la part d'ombré de zelensky
ya un mystère hélène ce qui est il ya
aussi l'homme d'affaires le business
event qui ça existe cet empire du rire
qu'il a montée grâce à un homme qui
s'appelle et gore co molosses qui al
molky cow boys qui alias bnia qui est il
c'est un oligarque sulfureux il fait
partie de cette petite caste qui s'est
très rapidement et dans des proportions
effrayantes enrichi au moment de
l'indépendance 91 ans pratiquant la
captation des richesses de l'état c'est
à dire que là ce moment là il ya une
grande libéralisation on vend certaines
des entreprises nationalité en had
nationaliser pardon en réalité elles
sont bradés et certains profitent de
leur connexion de leurs positions et
bien pour agréger créer des monopoles et
s'enrichir encore une fois dans des
proportions titre pharaonique lui igor
colomiers que vous voyez à l'écran du
bnia il donne à zelensky la plate forme
puisqu'il possède une chaîne de
télévision qui va permettre à zelensky
de faire croître sa réalité et de
diffuser la série serviteur du peuple
qui va à la fois être carton 20 millions
de téléspectateurs la première saison
sachant que le pays compte 44 millions
d'habitants c'est vous dire à trop
porter de cette preuve d soir qui
devient c'est marrant c'est l'ukraine
dans la série il gagne l'élection avec
63% dans la réalité l'a gagné avec 73%
et je terminerai juste en disant qu'il
va se servir qui va instrumentaliser
cette série qui devient la fois
prophétique mais aussi programmatique
ouais il ya un chapitre aussi zelensky
qui est juif et vous on en parle
finalement très peu lui en parle très
peu mais c'était un juif l'oeil qui ne
revendique pas trop d'ailleurs son
identité pourtant ces centrales parce
que la russie a pu voilà désigné
l'ennemi les nazis c'est toute la
propagande de poutine et en même temps
évidemment on répondait le monde
occidental les ukrainiens ils ont élu un
juif en quoi c'est important et en quoi
c'est important aussi par rapport à
certaines accusations concernant
certains ukrainiens combattant le régime
en azote qui eux peuvent être dans les
faits effectivement néo nazi antisémite
alors il ya deux choses d'abord si cette
question refait surface et j'essaie de
l'expliquer dans cette biographie
ça vient de l'extérieur et c'est
systématiquement systématiquement le cas
avec volodymyr zensi comme avec beaucoup
de juifs russes ou juifs ukrainiens
c'est à dire que eux ne font pas du tout
de cette part de leur identité un
élément central de leur manière de se
définir mais quand vladimir poutine dit
je vais d nazifié l'ukraine alors que le
président est juive que le chef du
cabinet présidentiel est d'ascendance
juive tout comme le ministre de la
défense force est de constater qu'à
quelque chose de quand même très absurde
dans ses accusations concernant les
régiments azoff et vous avez raison de
poser cette question les très
importantes les spécialistes avec
lesquels je me suis entretenu explique
que dans la matrice idéologique de ce
régiment il y a effectivement de
l'ultranationalisme de l'idéologie
d'extrême droite mais que dans leur
champ politique le juif est totalement
hors contexte l'ennemi autour duquel ils
se retrouvent et autour duquel il
dessine cette idéologie ultra
nationalistes c'est le russe c'est
l'ennemi russe s'est pas du tout les
juifs et d'ailleurs il ya des juifs qui
servent dans ce régiment dans ces unités
vous faites bien de le rappeler
l'actualité de ce conflit pour terminer
ce soit aussi
des propos qui ont surpris à la
télévision d'état russe où il avait
entendu le monde entier est contre nous
pour la première fois la télévision
russe s'inquiète d'une défaite comment
vous interpréter cela c'est une personne
qui a tenu ses propos ça fait couler
énormément d'encre parce que c'est une
émission qui est très regardée animé par
une présentatrice qu'on connaît
désormais bien notoire pour son ton
pro-russe vraiment vraiment là est-ce
qu'on assiste à un début de basculement
je ne le pense pas mais en tous les cas
cet homme a eu l'honnêteté de
reconnaître une situation qui
objectivement est réel et ce qu'il sera
entendu suivi je ne le sais pas zelensky
l'ukraine dans le sens est aux éditions
du rocher merci beaucoup gallagher
fenwick d'être venu par le plateau sur
le plateau de lcp et je précise que à
l'ailé droite ce livre vont être
reversés aux mouvements france ukraine
merci infiniment à l'essai l'heure
d'accueillir nos a franchi pour leur
parti pris ce soir elle va monde un gars
vice et infos coulisses sur la campagne
des législatives
la sémiologue mariette darrigrand
s'interroge sur l'appellation officielle
première ministre ait pu paniquer
dauchez pour l'économie qui analyse les
bons chiffres du chômage plein emploi en
simple est ce que c'est possible dans un
franchi les voici bonsoir à vous trois
et merci d'être là on va commencer avec
vous elsa les législatives comme tous
les soirs et focus ce soir sur paris
paris divisé en 18 circonscriptions
certaines circonscriptions sont à
surveiller de près exactement c'est le
cas de la quinzième circonscription elle
englobe une grosse partie du 20e
arrondissement est là le match va se
jouer à gauche la candidate investie par
la nuque c'est danielle simonnet sur le
terrain elle a toujours son éternelle
veste rouge proche de jean luc mélenchon
mais elle fera face à une candidature
dissidente celle de la socialiste lamia
el harrach élus députés lors d'une
partielle en 2021 contre la même
danielle simonnet élection annulée six
mois plus tard c'est un des points de
crispation entre les insoumis et les
socialistes ils n'ont pas réussi à
s'entendre elles seront donc l'une
contre l'autre les 12 et 19 juin
prochain on surveillera également la
circo numéro 4 les beaux quartiers 16e
17e c'est une des deux dernière
circonscription de la droite à paris la
députée brigitte kuster elle entend bien
conserver son monde mais ça va être
compliqué emmanuel macron il a fait plus
de 45 % des voix au premier tour et il
envoie une fidèle astrid panossian
bouvet trésorière de la république en
marche historique du mouvement enfin des
cirques au l'a6 l'a7 la trêve et les
faits c'est pas l'auto ce sont des
circonscriptions détenues par la
majorité mais là où le député sortant ne
se représente pas c'est le cas de pierre
person de pacôme rupins du grand saut ou
encore de mounir ben joue be c'était
donc des points de chute londres est
très convoité on y retrouve pêle mêle un
sénateur un ministre et deux anciens
conseillers un d'emmanuel macron l'hôte
de sophie cluzel bonjour conserver
probablement ces circonscriptions on
imagine elle va vous voyez nous parler
aussi du coup de colère des
représentants de la nuque baisse
exactement la règle toujours d'accord
pour savoir si on dit la nuit plagne où
paissent mais en tout cas il voulait
absolument partir sous une bannière
commune
je vous explique lors des élections
législatives les candidats choisissent
leur étiquette mais c'est
l'administration qui choisit les nuances
publication du ministère de l'intérieur
coup de colère des représentants de la
nuque il n'y figure pas mais s'est
séparé france insoumise parti socialiste
il il voit une manoeuvre des manuels
macron écouter julien bayou pour europe
ecologie les verts nous évidemment on
souhaite être rattaché à la nuance du ps
la nouvelle union populaire écologique
et sociale pourquoi les différentes
candidatures soient considérés et
additionnés pour qu'on voit le vrai
rapport de force au soir du premier tour
ça une vraie importance de de retracer
la sincérité du scrutin alors l'argument
du ministère de l'intérieur c'est que
chaque partie a lui même investi ses
candidats et donc ils partent sous les
couleurs du parti ce qui n'est pas le
cas par exemple dans la majorité avec la
confédération est ensemble cette
explication ne convainc pas jean luc
mélenchon et ses partenaires ils se
disent prêts à aller jusqu'en justice
puisqu'on conseil d'état à faire affaire
à suivre merci beaucoup elsa on continue
sur les législatives puisque elle est en
campagne notre nouvelle première
ministre
mariette darrigrand vous voulez revenir
sur la formulation officielle de
première ministre oui parce que les
nouvelles lorsqu'il dit qu'ils sont est
arrivée à matignon c'est l'été premier
ministre a été nommé comme ça et ensuite
on a dit c'est une femme premier
ministre tandis que là on a deux mots
qui s'accordent ou qui s'accorde au parc
oui c'est vrai qu'il ya une sorte de
choc de genre d'une certaine voilà voilà
donc ça c'est le problème du français en
anglais n'y a pas de souci puisque prime
minister pipi m c'est neutre en fait et
donc il n'y a aucun souci pour que pour
nommer un homme et une femme de la même
façon mais nous en français évidemment
nous sommes héritiers du latin et en
latin il y avait beaucoup de gens
viennent avec trois d'ailleurs il y
avait le masculin et le féminin et le
nôtre et quand je vous ai dit que
ministre était masculin alors que
première gymnaste c'est pas vrai c'est
pas un ministre n'est pas masculin
ministre est neutre mais ce très neutre
alors on va écouter eric zemmour parce
que lui il a déjà sa petite idée sur
cette nouvelle formulation cette
nouvelle appellation écouter première
ministre salue l'arrivée du nouveau
premier ministre que ce soit un homme ou
une femme si elle est compétente projet
toujours dit ça pendant toute la
campagne vous l'avez nouveau premier
ministre vous dis pas première ministre
c'est moche non à l'autre à l'oreille
moi vous savez le français pour moi je
dois d'abord être beau donc oui c'est le
nouveau premier ministre à la shac
sonore pour c'est un choc ce n'est en
fait c'est un choc cognitif parce que on
ne peut pas effectivement accordé du
masculin et du féminin alors qu'est ce
qui se passe c'est ben depuis hier
jusqu'à intéressant sur elisabeth bornes
elle reçoit en quelque sorte des
qualificatifs neutre épicène on appelle
ça et pis elle n'a donc par exemple
techno techno c'est sympa de gens
perfectionniste solide inflexible aussi
donc je crois qu'on va avoir avec elle
cette neutralisation du féminin est ce
que ça veut dire qu'il faudrait dire
première ministre est bas au 19e siècle
on aurait pu le dire le mot existait
encore mais bon ils n'étaient pas
extrêmement positif c'était soit la
femme du ministre soit la servante mais
il y a quand même dans ministre cette
idée de servir servir l'état serviteur
du culte etc mais pourquoi justement il
faut féminisé l'adjectif première alors
c'est un peu les deux familles celle
house est l'exemple de notre premier
ministre nous concerne toutes les femmes
aujourd'hui parce que en fait si on est
on est à un moment où il ya deux
féminisme qui sont qui ne s'opposent pas
qu'ils sont concomitants mais qui disent
pas la même chose le premier féminisme
nous dans la tradition finalement nous
sommes des hommes comme les autres nous
avons accès à la gravité employés bien
sûr le visage d'elisabeth borny hier la
responsabilité l'éthique l'intelligence
d'éducation etc donc nous sommes neutres
et c'est très bien alors que pendant des
siècles nous avons été un peu assigne à
résidence dans le corps dans la chair et
c'est donc ça c'est une première chose
mais la deuxième chose qui est peut-être
plus contemporaine c'est qu'on remet du
féminin parce que les faux nom de la
visibilité à sion
les femmes ont été un visibiliser par
des siècles par exemple pas d'écrivaine
tout le monde est écrivain et c'est donc
on a eu qui revient c'est ça le deux
premières donc elisabeth bornes elle est
à la conjonction de ces deux mouvements
et j'ai dit très exactement mais chacune
d'entre nous d'une certaine façon ce qui
était intéressant quand elle est arrivée
hier sur le perron de matignon c'est que
je trouve qu'on voyait ça très bien
physiquement elle était à la fois neutre
comme jean castex mais quand même elle
avait tenu c'est assez rare chez elle à
se mettre en jupe avoir une petite veste
cintrée des talons et c'est rare d'avoir
d'ailleurs quand on voit le français
s'approprient cette première ministre
c'est j'ose dire politiquement aussi
sémantiquement merci exact merci
beaucoup mariette allez on file sur le
chômage avec vous fanny ce soir on a les
chiffres qui sont plutôt bons on peut se
réjouir baisse de 7 à 7,3 pour cent de
la population c'est du jamais vu depuis
depuis 2008 effectivement c'est une très
bonne nouvelle justement pour élise
avait deux bornes qui démarre ce nouveau
mandat à matignon alors si presque un
point de mieux par rapport à avant la
crise sanitaire et c'est le signe qu'on
est vraiment dans une reprise que notre
économie en ce début d'année puisque
c'est des chiffres qui couvrent le
premier trimestre et bien la reprise est
plus forte que prévu mais attention tout
de même parce que ça montre un petit
ralentissement quand on regarde par
rapport à la fin de l'année dernière on
était à 7,4 finalement c'est moins une
baisse est plutôt une stabilité et
baisse à un peu notre taux de chômage
c'est l'épaisseur du trait à quoi faccin
ce ralentissement alors ça tient à la
guerre en ukraine qui a démarré fin
février donc qui a qui est souffle un
peu l'économie on voit l'association
d'ailleurs des cadres à noter que le
marché de l'emploi était très bon pour
les cadres mais qui avait déjà des
intentions d'embauché qui étaient
remises à plus tard il ya une inflexion
et ça n'est pas terminée malheureusement
parce que cette guerre en ukraine va à
prioris poursuivre ça tient aussi au
confinement en chine à une économie
globale qui est ralentie avec tout ce
que l'on connaît des pénuries des
problèmes d'approvisionnement une baisse
de la consommation et de l'inflation qui
fait que bah du coup on dépense moins on
épargne les entreprises produisent moins
et puis du coup elles embauchent moins
parce que tout le monde est inquiet dans
ce contexte international qui n'est pas
très favorable ça veut dire que le
chômage pourrait repartir à la hausse et
la swiss et le risque plusieurs voyants
de notre économie qui étaient au vert
très verts sont en train de virer à l'
orange de quoi compliquer la tâche
d'elisabeth baume qui vient d'arriver et
le rêve du plein emploi et bien écoutez
à 5% comme le voudraient et manuellement
à compliquer l éloignent un petit peu
plus alors on verra si après avoir été
une des rares ministre du travail qui a
vu cette fameuse courbe du chômage
baisser elizabeth banks reine de la
remontée vers à remonter avant une
mauvaise nouvelle pour terminer on verra
quand reverra on verra merci infiniment
merci les affranchis pour voir ou revoir
cette émission la chaîne youtube de lcp
tout de suite votre soirée documentaire
coming out de denis parrot en cette
journée mondiale contre l'homophobie
très belle soirée et à demain
[Musique]